all right so dave gettleman did trade
down twice for the first time
in his career as a general manager and i
love the trade down from 11 to 20.
once they got leapfrogged for devonta
smith by the eagles who jumped from 12
to 10. their next receiver was kedarius
tony
they got him nine spots later and
they picked up more stuff they got a
first round pick next year from the
chicago bears to go down to 20
and get the guy that if they had to put
a name on the card at 12 very well may
have been the name they put on the card
chris
yeah i mean it's it's impressive i mean
the giants
great off season you know yeah okay
maybe overpaid a little bit we know for
kenny gallaudet but still got players
they needed
addressed you know addressed issues on
their team and cadarius tony
you know yeah you missed devonte smith
okay all right we'll take this freak of
nature that's very tyree kill-ish
and we heard urban meyer yesterday how
badly he wanted kedarius tony
so it is it was a great job by gettleman
not only that move right there to still
address the same position the offense is
dangerous
but that is huge the first round pick
for next year and a year where we
know all gms and everybody felt more
comfortable picking
as compared to this year and then even
the second round
to do business with the patriots and
trade down and then again
address what i think they were worried
about and what they needed to address
which was an
edge defender and get aziz ojolari
from from georgia a perfect giants new
england outside
linebacker physical type of guy so i
i really i'm a i'm a big fan gentleman
i think has been thrown under the bus a
little too much here in new york i think
for the most part he's done a pretty
damn good job
and i think that's continued here
through the off-season i mean i i like
the giants draft
so much of it though rests on
quarterback daniel jones top 10 pick a
couple of years ago and
we see these moves they are eliminating
systematically any and all excuses
that's it
that daniel jones could have and they
want him to have that josh allen type of
a jump
this year yeah no judge was on the
michael k show on espn radio
yesterday talking about daniel jones
and how injuries may be one of the
reasons why he has yet to become
a shortlist franchise quarterback here's
judge from yesterday
look dan is the last guy that's going to
use anything as an excuse what i would
say about the injury last year is
look it was it was much more serious
than maybe
people thought on the outside i'd say
probably 90 of the players in the league
who would have had that injury including
quarterbacks uh would have been on irela
for the remainder of the year
that's just the reality of it it was
much more severe than you know
maybe he allowed people to know or the
information that was put out there and
we're going to protect our players by
not
disclosing everything about their
injuries to be honest with you but
you know he fought through a lot of
things here and a lot of people's
respect through what it was
he's a guy that you have a lot of
confidence in just because of how
the way you see them work on a daily
basis
gotta tread lightly when you talk about
things like that the last thing that the
giants need is the nfl to go back and
start comparing
the details and specifics of the injury
reports
to other records that the team may have
you know it happened
when ben roethlisberger had his elbow
injury week two of 2019 and he was done
for the year and he hadn't been on the
injury report the steelers got
fined for that and it's not a huge fine
but it's just an issue that you don't
want you don't need it's an unforced
error to go into that minefield and
he was kind of on the fringes of that
minefield by talking about
what daniel jones played through what he
didn't play through look guys play
through all kinds of stuff
and anytime they say it's not an excuse
and then they give you the excuse it's
still an excuse
just because they use the preface it's
not an excuse or i don't want to make
excuses then then don't say it
at all yeah you don't want to make
excuses don't make excuses
saying i don't want to make excuses
doesn't make the excuse that you follow
it with not an excuse
yeah i know i mean you're right you're
right i i don't think it's being used to
do
excuses i think it's more to shed the
light like joe judge in this situation
on the human being
he's trying to like let everybody know
like hey he's really respected in our
locker room
because of these things the public
doesn't know this
and i think he's trying to get the
public to like hey respect this guy
there's a little more to him than
than maybe you realize i do think
there's great respect within that
organization for daniel jones one that's
they believe in him like joe judge said
the work ethic
all those type of things he's tough as
hell i mean he's
he's tough to in it to it it's you know
it's a little bit of like a gift and a
curse
it's what's caused these problems we're
watching right here and all of that
he'll stand in the pocket like the
statue of liberty in the middle of the
hudson river
with people all around them and not move
or not do anything
and he just he takes too many big hits i
mean look at this
it's just it's it's been like this for
two years now and that's where
he's got to adjust his game not only for
himself so his career lasts but two
the fumbling problem is real and that
that those are two things
i mean or one thing he's really got a
fix about his football game
and back to your original point i think
that's like the point here more than
anything
man they're gonna know if daniel jones
is the quarterback of the future after
this year
like you said there's no excuse the
pressure has now been swung in the
giants organization to me
to yes daniel jones and jason garrett
and they
they're gonna have to formulate
something here that makes this
offense you know fun and explosive and
puts up yards and points there's too
much talent
you know there's too many big names now
there's too much money thrown out there
to some of these guys there's gonna be a
spotlight
on this offense and how it performs
and uh we'll see hopefully that means
good things for big blue daniel jones
and all giants fans
one of the first points you made when we
started working together four years ago
that caused me to think you know what i
may be wrong about this guy he may know
a thing or two about the game
is when you said when you're just gonna
let that one go
when you said that eli manning was
screwed up
because the blocking was so bad
the clock in his head was accelerating
and at times he was throwing the ball
when he didn't have to right because he
was
hyper aware yes of the fact that the
walls were going to close in
right and i see daniel jones who hasn't
adjusted at all
no his clock no to
yeah and and we thought we would see
that last year but i think that's job
number one for jason garrett
getting this guy to make his read faster
get rid of the football more
quickly because when you hold on to it
you get hit the more you get hit the
more you get hurt
and then we got to go with the backup
whoever the backup is this year
and the more you get hit when the ball's
in your hand the more likely the ball is
going to be bouncing around on the turf
and the other team's gonna recover it
and they're gonna get a cheap seven or
three points
and it's gonna make it even harder for
us to win the game so there are multiple
reasons why they have to accelerate the
clock yeah in daniel jones head yeah
there definitely is and
you know yeah i think he's a good kid
he's trying to
you know take the coaching hey i'm going
through the reads that's what happens to
a lot of these guys a lot of the times
added to the fact that you know he spent
his early part of his career probably
witnessing eli manning and those things
and probably
had the coaches telling him like hey you
know sit in the pocket here we
would have liked eli to sit in the
pocket here and make this throw so
that's probably in his mind a little bit
too
but it is mike you're right that's the
next phase it's got to change this year
he can't be putting them in bad
situations and taking sacks to make it
second and 17
or fumbling the ball and doing those
type of things and added to that
we know he's a pretty damn good athlete
i know he tripped and fell but damn he
ran 80 yards before that he's had a lot
of other damn good runs too
so it is it's about he needs to add it's
a little like uh
like we talked about with kellen monde
in the draft right
he needs to add a little bit more of a
backyard element to his game
it just it can't always be in the pocket
you don't have the 2007 patriots
offensive line
it's got to be one two three real quick
start looking around
get the hell out of there throw the ball
away do something but uh it is the
biggest issue with his game
you're spot on about that you either
have it or you don't
or you have the ability to acquire it
this is the year that we find out
whether or not he has the ability to
acquire it
and if he doesn't maybe aaron rodgers
will indeed
be the quarterback of the giants next
year although i think that's unlikely
dave gettleman that would be awesome
that would be so awesome for everything
would you
would you would you authorize rogers to
change the number 11. oh
what i'd be like screw you dad you
better let him have the jersey
screw you he's aaron rodgers he wants to
wear 11 the hell with it
well we'll we'll retire it again after
he's done wearing it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports